Welcome to Film Tonight.
This episode, I'm joined by two
of the funniest folks alive,
the stars of Night School,
Kevin Hart and Tiffany Haddish.
-Hey.
-Hey, Josh.
-What's up, Josh?
-Hey.
-Thanks so much for stopping by.
-Yeah.
Since your new film is about
going back to school,
Tiffany, I'm wondering
what do you think
you'd say to your
18 year old self?
Always be true to who you are,
'cause you are a unicorn.
That's good.
-That's inspiring.
-That's great. That's great.
What about for you, Kevin,
what do you think you'd say
to 18 year old Kevin Hart?
For one, I would say don't drink
too much at the
Super Bowl party.
Joking, Josh.
Man, what would I say?
I don't know. I don't know.
There's a lot that I would say.
You know, 18 year old me.
Well, we actually have
a little surprise for you.
Joining us right now here
in studio, Kevin,
meet your actual
18 year old self.
What do you mean my actual 18-
Come on out.
Damn.
What the fuck?
Who the hell?
Time out.
Is that a time portal.
Do you know how
3D printers work?
-No.
-Kinda like that.
What? Are you ...
Are you kidding me?
This is not Kevin, okay?
Are you blind? Look at me.
Look at ...
I was going through
a awkward phase.
I was so stupid.
A awkward phase?
Are you serious?
Were you sawed in half
by a magician
who forgot to reattach
the other half?
Talkin' about cut me in half?
This is a full beef burger,
okay.
This is a big burger.
You like a slider.
Talkin' 'bout a couple inches,
Tiffany.
Could be an inch or two.
You know what it was?
Coffee.
Really?
I was drinking back
to back cups of coffee
and that's what
stunted me a little bit.
But other than that,
this is exactly what it was.
Okay, I need a DNA test
'cause this is not you.
I can prove it's me. Watch this.
Hey, young Kev, do the tongue
thing we used to do.
The tongue thing.
I mean, there it is.
I don't know if this proves it,
but I like it.
What?
I think we're missing
the point here.
-What do you think-
-God dang.
I used to do that all the time.
Oh my God. I think I'm pregnant.
I had a gland problem.
I used to sweat,
and I used to do this
because I would start stinking,
so I took my shirts off.
They used to tease me.
"Look at Kev all out of shape.
You need to get
in the gym, Kev."
Man, thank God I finally did.
This is beautiful.
That is not beautiful.
I feel like we've gotten off
topic.
This is an amazing
opportunity, Kevin.
What else do you wanna say
to your 18 year old self?
You know, look. You're gonna
go through a situation
where you find out you got IBS,
which is irritable
bowel syndrome.
I didn't find out
'til I was older.
There's groups that you could
talk to about it,
and when you come together
and realize that as a people,
that other people
are suffering from ...
Hey, man.
Hey, Tiffany.
Stop talking to young me
while I'm talking to young me.
Is this gon' fuck up the space
time continuum or something?
Nah, we should be fine.
Okay, well then I'm gonna
have me some fun.
It's all fun and games
'til you realize
I had unbelievable gas.
Every five minutes, pap, pap,
pap, pap, pap, pap,
pap,
like a goddamn road of pellets,
I would just leave.
Milk.
That's all the time
we have on Film Tonight.
See you next time.
Thanks, man.
Yeah. Hey, Josh,
this is a messed up show.
It's just not ...
it's just not good.